[Musica]
il coraggio delle
idee Voglio condividere con voi una
frase di Roberto Ben iniziare un nuovo
cammino spaventa ma dopo ogo che
percorriamo ci rendiamo conto di quanto
fosse pericoloso rimanere fermi Beh
quando si parla di coraggio delle idee
bisogna intendersi bene perché se
pensiamo al coraggio nella letteratura
piuttosto che in
psicologia subito Consideriamo che sia
la capacità umana di affrontare le cose
difficili ma non è così il coraggio è la
forza di compiere scelte corrette per
noi di abbandonar alla felicità e ai
successi il coraggio emotivo in
particolare è la difesa delle proprie
convinzioni ciascuno di noi diventi
Ambasciatore del coraggio è più facile
fare la cosa giusta che sentiamo per noi
che quella sbagliata dobbiamo essere
pronti ad accogliere il nostro
intuito
e questo è in ogni ambito della vita
dalla famiglia al lavoro ai rapporti
sociali e anche nello sport porsi
traguardi graduali e obiettivi diciamo a
lungo respiro non è una speranza è il
modo per crescere Anzi è l'unico modo
per crescere
ovviamente l'eccezione potrebbe essere
semplicistica non semplice quasi banale
e Sì belle parole ma volte non è facile
ci sono sempre tanti fattori esterni che
condizionano
Ebbene per me questa è la più grande
sciocchezza che potremmo
raccontarci nessuno può turbare la
ricerca della nostra felicità nessuno
potrà mai avere un'idea pertinente per
noi stessi nessuno potrà mai rivendicare
verità superiori Questi non sono deliri
di onnipotenza e è che eh troppe volte
la gerarchia soffoca
l'identità troppe volte il consiglio
malcelati
troppe volte il genere mortifica le
competenze siate quindi responsabili di
voi stessi e quindi in grado anche di
sostenere gli altri
è molto prima che il termine resilienza
fosse così abusato eh Sono stata quasi
costretta a considerare come le
difficoltà devono essere necessariamente
vissute come delle opportunità e vi
prego di accogliere il racconto
confidenziale del mio passato del mio
vissuto che non è un insegnamento
ovviamente di vita è molto più
semplicemente
eh L'unica cosa che vi posso
dire quindi il il mio passato la mia
esperienza autentica che poi nella
realtà è la storia di tanti di noi Ecco
qui non voglio passare come Lady Oscar
ma mio padre desiderava un maschio come
primo figlio tanto che fino alla mia
nascita era assolutamente convinto che
io stessa fossi un
maschio mentre mia mamma mi spingeva a
fare da piccola discipline femminili
come la danza classica la ginnastica
artistica mio padre mi portava con lui
in palestra dove regolarmente per anni
Ho praticato arti marziali combattendo
con
eou omini Ecco mio padre un po' lo
conoscete è l'esempio vivente della
disciplina direi quasi dell'ostinazione
per lui dovevo essere sempre la più
forte a combattere la più resistente a
nuotare la più brava in tutto è stato un
percorso facile Certamente no mi ha
aiutato Certamente sì però vedete non
devo essere mal
interpretata quella rigidità non mi ha
aiutato a essere disciplinata mi ha
aiutato a essere libera che è molto di
più
forse sono a qualcuno di voi sembrerà un
paradosso e quindi vi devo spiegare
meglio quando si è bambini e poi giovani
adolescenti ragazzi si è talmente
Digiuni di vita e impreparati verso il
mondo che l'unico modello a cui si tende
è determinato dall'imitazione
genitoriale e forse ancor di più dal
desiderio di non deluderli io
personalmente
aggiungo che vedevo i miei genitori
pochissimo e quindi avvertivo una
pulsione quasi violenta a renderli
orgogliosi di me a scuola a danza nello
studio del pianoforte e nelle discipline
sportive crescendo ho avuto il
privilegio di poter realizzare che tutto
questo sforzo nella realtà lo compivo
per me non per
loro a un certo punto della mia vita
senza che svolgi chissà quali
ragionamenti Ho scoperto come io fossi
al centro della mia vita ero ormai
diventata grande in psicologia si
direbbe che avevo Risso il cordone
ombelicale Ecco Devo però dirvi che se
la mia francazi personale è stata
disinvolta quella professionale è stata
molto complicata Mi sono laureata in
scienze e tecnologie alimentari con una
tesi sperimentale ho conseguito poi un
master in biochimica in quel momento mi
sentivo pronta a spaccare il mondo Ero
certa che avrei apportato grandi
cambiamenti alla realtà imprenditoriale
dei miei genitori ero anche sicura che
le mie competenze le mie idee sarebbero
state da loro accolte con la fiducia con
fiducia e disinvoltura e che mi
avrebbero riconosciuto spazio libertà e
tante altre cose inutile dire che mi
sbagliassi sono entrata in pasticceria e
quel primo giorno dopo la laurea anziché
tacco e taur hooss ho indossato delle
scarpe antiinfortunistiche ero talmente
arrabbiata che mi sarebbe servita la la
museruola altro che pursu sonorum sono
stata collocata in magazzino spostavo
scatole organizzavo l'approvvigionamento
lo stoccaggio delle materie prime
Insomma ero l'ultima dei dipendenti Dopo
anni sono stata collocata al bancone
inserivo le Mignon nei pirottini servivo
i clienti capitemi bene cioè Allora come
oggi non mi difettava l'utilità
semplicemente ero convinta che le mie
idee le mie competenze
potessero aiutare l'azienda a crescere e
la prima svolta è intervenuta con
l'e-commerce e ve la vorrei
raccontare Chi produce deve vendere e
questo è semplice ed essenziale per
quanto arrivassero ordini telefonici da
tutta Italia e non solo non Era
immaginabile che mia madre potesse
trascorrere ore ore al telefono segnando
su bigliettini volanti le richieste dei
clienti c'era un'organizzazione
un
po' non eravamo particolarmente
organizzati da questo punto di vista era
impossibile quasi pianificare la
produzione non si poteva
costruire un planning distinguendo
prodotti da mantenere nel negozio e la
quota da spedire le stesse spedizioni
inevitabilmente erano disor orzate i
corrieri arrivavano a picciolate a volte
più volte nel corso del giorno
intralciando così l'attività di vendita
la gestione della della contabilità era
perfettibile e Ciò nonostante nonostante
tutti lavorassimo 16-17 ore al giorno mi
sono quindi rivolta a un programmatore
conferendogli l'incarico per fare un
sito che in più desse anche una
piattaforma e-commerce
ehm il preventivo era nei limiti del
modesto budget datemi dao datomi da mio
padre l'applicativo era semplice e
intuitivo ero trionfante avremmo potuto
raggiungere tutta l'Europa destinando i
nostri prodotti in tutte le case senza
esternalizzare nulla con le mie certezze
sono andata dai miei genitori Ecco le le
reazioni Secondo mia mamma avremmo
incasinato la contabilità e i pacchi per
per le spedizioni avrebbero tolto spazio
alla vendita mio padre se ne uscì con la
frase se vogliono panettone se lo
vengono a prendere in negozio
Beh non commento solo posso dirvi che
non sapevo se essere più mortificata o
più arrabbiata all'esito di trattative
che al confronto la pace di versail
sembrava un'assemblea di classe alle
medie sono riuscita a strappare il
consenso il fatto però era che io solo
io mi sarei occupata della gestione
degli ordini Ho passato i primi due anni
a stampare i bollettini fino a notte
alta e e all'alba andavo in pasticceria
la mattina con le etichette prestampate
da attaccare alle scatole e le riempivo
di
prodotti per aumentare la visibilità e
prima ancora avevo creato i social
Facebook Instagram e tutti gli altri e
In brevissimo tempo l'e-commerce ha
iniziato a fatturare come un secondo
negozio in pochi anni siamo cresciuti
del
600% il passaggio successivo era quello
di aprire un secondo punto vendita E
inevitabilmente il pensiero è andato
verso la città di Milano ne ho parlato
con papà è stata preferisco avere un
negozio che funziona piuttosto che due
che vanno male direi Non male come
incentivo
da qui in poi con mio fratello Nicola
abbiamo creato e gestito un laboratorio
di ricerca e sviluppo e produzione dopo
un paio di anni con l'ingresso di nuovi
soci la progressione è stata assai
rapida abbiamo aperto nuovi negozi
inaugurato molti pop-up Store e pensato
a ulteriori Format e collaborazioni
anche in termini di cob
branding il filo conduttore in questo
fondo che unisce Passato presente e
futuro è composto da due parole coraggio
e innovazione tutto ciò Mette in
discussione una convenzione porta
beneficio il coraggio delle idee è la
chiave per liberare il potenziale
dell'Innovazione
l'innovazione È il pensiero che precorre
ogni azione in pasticceria però è
necessario avere delle particolari
accortezze perché ogni mutamento non può
che partire dalla tradizione non si
tratta fatto di essere conservatori e e
mench meno reazionari il gusto
l'estetica i sapori i gusti aromatici
costituiscono una parte identitaria del
nostro bagaglio esperienziale e non
possono essere violati il nostro compito
è quindi quello di comprendere il
passato saperlo riconoscere e
rispettarlo e infine innovar
il coraggio di mettere in linea una
produzione artigianale di creare il
primo Brand di lusso nella pasticceria
Vallato per altro dalla
giurisprudenza e contraddistinto
ehm Scusate da un'esperienza accogliente
e accessibile ai più alla fine di questa
nostra chiacchierata voglio concludere
affrontando il vaglio della qualità più
essenziale di ogni imprenditore la forza
dell'esempio la reputazione non è quello
che gli altri raccontano di noi perché
ridurremo l'argomento a un pettegolezzo
la reputazione è prima ancora come noi
ci poniamo al nostro esterno essere
credibili è essenziale per noi stessi
identifica i nostri valori pulsioni
desideri
aspettative convinzioni speranze e
quindi realtà mi sono resa conto che
quello che viene particolarmente
apprezzato della nostra persona ed
essere mamma moglie imprenditrice
sportiva curiosa appassionata fragile e
forte al tempo stesso come ultima frase
Voglio voglio dirvi una cosa mia se nel
nostro piccolo vogliamo lasciare una
traccia sicura dobbiamo essere testimoni
di noi stessi indicatori della via della
crescita forse molto più semplicemente e
autenticamente coraggiosi delle nostre
idee
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Grazie